KST we carry the shipping instantly
I know patience is the key put enough on
my ship for free
this is t we carry feet michael make up
what's good t fam it's me Gary good
morning it is May 13th
we are fully in it at this point in the
Cobras crisis everyone's talking about
the new norm you mean norm hope
everybody's super well let me give some
shoutouts before we get into it Dustin
how are you excellent excellent showered
for first shower in two days so I feel I
feel good I remember yeah it didn't mean
I hate doing that but now it is now it's
normal Courtney Lord what's good Shane
oh what's good Kim good to see you
strategy goddess thank you so much for
being here real estate BJ great thank
you for being your hakim Draper what's
good on the west coast at six am life
big shout out to the twitch fam Rosa for
health James oh good to see you Darren F
Thank You Casey
Carrie Gardner let's get into the show
what's good what's good brother how you
doing I'm not showered up bro I'm
feeling good it's early for me man your
West Coast in it
mm-hmm East Coast southeast the 9 a.m.
is early yeah I still early yeah your go
to bed at 2:00 3:00 4:00 a.m. something
like that yeah yeah yeah man how's the
musical good good good I just um I just
saw a republic about a month ago I got
some records coming out with Diplo and
Postma long and some big [ __ ] coming so
be here thank you bro thank you how do
you feel right now I know you're sitting
on those tracks and you're no dope like
you know that that's gonna give you a
bunch of looks like do you think like
damn this this quote-unquote might be it
and and are you also mentally prepared
because people have done things with
huge artists and sometimes it's not the
moment and it sometimes happens four
years later are you in the mindset of
like I'm ready for if it pops off or I'm
ready for it to be a disappointment and
then it will happen in a couple years
like are you in that mindset no you know
I think I'm ready for it to pop off I
you know I know that even if it doesn't
like it completely explode over time
it's gonna get me enough looks you know
I mean that's that's worth it I was uh I
was actually watching a video of yours
on Instagram the other day that was like
one is greater than zero and it was it
was really motivating as far as you know
just taking the little views you know to
me I love that video too for me
personally because that's the one that
shows even right now I've unlimited
videos on YouTube that have 137 219 400
to vide and I tell people all the time
like do [ __ ] like people like value
their time a lot of times when when it's
not valuable and so like putting in the
work yes for sure but I mean you know
you got a song with them post Molalla
it's really not gonna be that much of a
disappointment if it doesn't blow up
it's still gonna it's still gonna blow
up in a sense you know right you're
gonna get another artists are gonna take
a look and other producers
take a look and other people gonna take
a look right he's just so huge that it's
like you know it's a big it's a big
opportunity I'm really ready to get my
album underway and really you know kind
of push my stuff in a big way but we got
some features that you know during this
quarantine downtime stuff like that I
think it really kind of keeps me fueled
that you know I mean there's some big
big views coming
you know the main here and I can't wait
to see it happen what can I do for you
well you know I get asked a lot as
upcoming artists and I'm not where I
want to be yet but I still get a lot of
aspiring artists that come to me asking
for advice on you know how to how to
make it in music you know in general or
you know they'll say how do you how did
you get this post Malone feature how did
you how did you meet juice world blase
Bob but you know I think a lot of it is
I would like to know I guess a good
response from you your side of it you
know maybe using some music based
examples just how he would go about
responding to an upcoming artist that
aspiring to be you know killing it and
it's an entertaining industry for me two
things stand out taking it and having it
come to you
so taking it is literally commenting
DMing on the biggest producers and
artists and you know world stars and a.k
just complex distribution places but not
doing what i see all the thirsty artists
do which is like leaving a comment on
you know on Ghana's latest post or the
baby's latest post or Meghna Stein's
latest post and saying like yo you got
to check out my beats I'm the [ __ ]
freshest in the game or like you know
they sleeping on me I'm the best pretty
like that's just not gonna work right
it's just too thirsty and so but what I
do think is when when there's a there's
a new you know key Glock or young boy
post and you go in there and you
actually analyze the song or you come
out and you you know like I really
really feel rowdy Rich's lyrics so like
if you're an artist or producer that
feels it and you
come in and you quote one line and you
tell people what you feel there or like
you know I listen to mozzies new album
like four times in a row and there's
just a lot of things that hit me if I
was an up-and-coming artist or a
producer I would go into those posts
because he's promoting the [ __ ] out of
his joint and leave thoughtful
thoughtful comments not thirsty comments
so that's that's going out and taking or
IDM mazi or the producers on that or his
manager and say yo that [ __ ] third
track when he said this or like you know
you just give love but thoughtful enough
not spamming but actually just genuinely
putting in the work so that's going and
taking it and that may catch someone's
attention because you know this is an
artist clever like you may have a deep
lyric that really means something to you
it's kind of subtle in a song nobody
gives a [ __ ] but if somebody comes
around like yo those nine words together
hit me you're gonna take note of that
it's the same way I take note when
people leave a comment my Instagram
about a certain part of a video that I
can see is not the spiky part it's not
the part that everybody caught on but I
knew what it meant to me that catches my
attention like oh that's a thoughtful
kid let me see what that's going on
artists do that too that's taking it and
then having it come to you is putting
out the [ __ ] work exactly yeah music
I believe in it like everybody you know
you know this you've been watching me
for a while like like I I believe that
putting out more music is good like I
genuinely do yeah you know I tell a lot
of people like the content everything
that you know keeping it consistent is
great a lot of people fail to do the
research that I think that it takes you
know just digging in and trying to you
know find those opportunities not just
you know doing all the social media
things but you know a lot of people
think you can just make the record and
shoot the video and put it out there and
pray to God you know what I mean and and
that's almost a hundred percent
guaranteed to not work almost a hundred
percent exactly and I it's hard to
explain it to some people like they
think it's just gonna catch fire and
what they have to realize there's a lot
of the viral videos that you you know
it's got a lot of work going into it I
know some record labels
put millions millions of dollars into
some marketing schemes for certain
artists to get certain songs at you know
at the number one spot you look at the
top fifty right now and you map it to
tick-tock this is why I've been [ __ ]
yelling at the top of my lungs for 18
months to every artist and every person
about tick tock yet if you get you know
I mean there was a moment when the baby
was in my office I'm like bro
tick tock like like you're already
ascending but you win in that
environment and and sure enough you know
a couple of quotes same thing with
little keyed you know like some of the
some of my guys have been really going
in there like tick tock you know five
tick tock influencers doing a dance to a
certain snippet of a song well
outperformed four million dollar media
spend by a [ __ ] record company every
day the week in 2020 you know and it
goes back to your one is greater than
zero thing even though even the the
small influencers I noticed when I
checked my stats on Spotify you get a
lot of a lot of plays that are you know
a thousand of them only have a hundred
plays or fifty plays you know but if
you're on a hundred thousand playlist
and those a hundred thousand playlist
all had a hundred plays on them that's a
lot of [ __ ] plays man so I believe in
that [ __ ] and by the way that's exactly
right and inevitably you've got one
important person that's digging deeper
and is on those small playlists and that
becomes the moment exactly that one
person you know it's a lot about who's
listening and not how meanings sometimes
because you know it there was a couple
of people trying to stop me from doing a
particular song and that particular song
that came out you know was something
that I was felt strongly about and
although people didn't necessarily feel
great about the song you know enough to
push it and put a bunch of money behind
it it just happened to be a song that
got noticed by Justin Bieber by post
Malone that ended up being a feature
that came out the next
here you know what I mean that it just
kind of keeps that consistency going you
know it's the single thing I believe in
the most which is when you make the
content you want to make versus the
content that people want you to make or
that it looks like you should be making
it's the it's the it's literally the
post I post at 8:30 this morning on
Instagram it's me and uh murder beats
you know and and it's me a year ago
telling him like yo tick tock and and
he's like yeah but I don't dance I'm
like no no no this you do what you do
and here we are a year later and tick
tock looks completely different than I
did a year ago when I was yelling 18
months ago a year ago everyone's like
fourteen-year-old girls and I was like
for now right yeah it's definitely huge
my tick tock is is slacking I believe
that tick tock is more important to you
than Spotify how about that
oh [ __ ] well and you might be right
I tend to go really hard on some of the
platforms that pay because I do so much
to the free stuff day but bro-bro
you do too smart that cuz you're super
thoughtful I'm loving this combo the
number one thing that pays is the place
where everybody's eyeballs are at even
though it's not paying you because those
eyeballs pay later right facts that's
that's huge facts you know I've got a
tick-tock minds at clever I made it look
look the part you know I've got the blue
check going on I kind of about 3000
followers which is you know club' listen
let's let's make this action-oriented
cuz I'm gonna jump the next call will
chop up in real life I can't wait you
need to post two or three times a day
and tick-tock it will change your game
I'm telling you okay hey you see now go
all-in I'm telling you yeah I'm with it
thank you so much got you a lot of fun
super smart kid I like his
thoughtfulness
good job Dustin I know you were playing
with the mic there I thought you did a
really good job that was challenging
yeah those times
toe gary shod Rashad real pleasure it's
awesome I'm excited to be here okay
real quick I just want to
say thank you a couple of couple of
times here thank you to you first of all
for the amount of content that you're
just given away for free you know so
many people want to charge for the words
coming out of their mouths so I
appreciate that and you know that you're
it's very simple and you cut through the
noise you know so right to the point
I appreciate the simplicity it comes
from natural to me and and I think that
we cloud our heads with so many things
are just our fake perception and it
stops us and so I appreciate it thank
you yeah and you know I definitely want
to thank your team you know Dustin and
Zane for coordinating things behind the
scenes I mean I don't think people
necessarily understand everything that's
going into producing this but you know
props to those guys for being on top of
things and coordinating so I agree I
think I think Justin's getting too much
credit and Dustin I agree you agree
right so I had a couple of questions
that I think caught the team's attention
they're a little a little while back you
know they've been trying to get me on
the show for a few days so um my first
question is just from the point of view
I'd like to get your perspective on what
you see as leadership and their
responsibilities during times of crisis
and I guess how do we how we recover
from crisis to what your perspective is
what's what's the biggest responsibility
they have to be compassionate some
sympathetic and empathetic to everybody
but themselves that's what I think the
responsibility is I think I think true
leadership is when you're when you
realize you're working for all of them
not the reverse
okay and I think it's very clear to me
when I see good leadership and when I
see bad leadership and so for me
great the responsibility of an actual
leader is to as the going gets tough to
be even more about their army than
themselves and so does that leader have
the humility the patience the empathy
the compassion the sympathy the kindness
to give [ __ ] about everybody but
themselves that takes you know self
deprecation that takes you know
selflessness it takes a lot of things
and so I think that's what I'm looking
for and that's
and I think a lot of you know to me only
the ultimate leader can go all the way
there me and my companies for example
because for example a lot of the leaders
of my companies I've noticed are worried
about their paycheck a worried about
their happiness and that's because
they're not at that ultimate leader spot
just yet and the and and then in other
people you see it there even though they
aren't the ultimate leader and then
you're like oh they have the attributes
to be an ultimate leader so it's about
so it's about those things so I think
the responsibility is to put it on their
shoulders it's on that yeah for sure
I agree I think it's great love the
perspective so moving on from that
unrelated question you know leadership
is a passion of why I've been loving the
leadership you know I mean leadership is
such a broad kind of term I guess but
you know I mean leadership in its form
and its art in its you know growing
yourself growing other people I love all
this stuff and I've recently kind of
made the jump to actually doing
something and you know it's been in my
heart for a long time to pursue that and
to train you know grow something out of
that and I mean really you I'm an infant
at this point you know having just kind
of kicked off my social platforms and
stuff like that and I'm trying to be you
know on tik-tok and Instagram and
Facebook and LinkedIn and Twitter and
I'm about to launch a website and a
podcast mm-hmm you know but like we're
four weeks into this and I I don't want
to get overwhelming that I want to
dilute what I'm trying to do and so I
just want to know what you believe it
would be the best actions for me to
focus in I think I think eliminating the
word deletion you know volume does not
mean deletion right so just keep pumping
it out I don't I don't feel diluted
saying [ __ ] you don't believe is
dilution yeah I get you but you can say
the same thing across 13 different
platforms the same exact thing thirteen
different ways cuz LinkedIn is different
in tik-tok and that means it's not
diluted the dilution comes in saying
[ __ ] you don't believe
[ __ ] you're talking about the dilution
does not come in the volume of creative
that is put out great I get it makes
sense people people focus on dilution or
quality in amount of pieces out I there
are some people that are diluted the
first [ __ ] words out of their mouth
because we're talking some [ __ ] yeah
doesn't matter if they only posted one
time yeah I think I end up thinking too
hard about about what I'm trying to say
in the you know I'm making train to try
to make really in-depth in deep
long-form content and stuff like that
it's just yeah you're you know I said
there's staring at my computer screen
for like you know this is sound good
does it not sound good it's even even in
the way you're you're doing this QA with
me it makes sense to me right like I
think you put thoughtfulness on a
pedestal which is amazing I think but I
think but I think that if you're
thoughtful it will come out you know I
think a lot of people think too much
about presentation like I come out like
you know there's a very good chance that
I'll go down as the kindness
entrepreneur of a generation yeah I
don't think that's how people saw me at
first with my [ __ ] cursing and
aggressiveness and competitiveness and
Jersey nough so what I mean by that is
the truth will always shine yeah it's
just the way it is there's no fighting
in life and so no matter how clever
people try to do or how much they
package it you know it's it's just so
obvious to me that you know it will all
ultimately play out no matter how
misunderstood I was for a decade a lot
of it's starting to play out and I
didn't think you know heck I think this
show has a lot to do with it mm-hmm and
yet you know I couldn't have predicted
kovat or you know I kind of predicted
tea with Gary B's so that clip from 10
years ago on Instagram but you know I
definitely um I definitely feel as
though you're overthinking it because if
you've got it
it will play out and if you don't it
will play out and I think you try to
package it you know is not going to be
the variable right yeah be thoughtful
you know very well by nature not by
sitting there and be tactically
thoughtful right
don't become a [ __ ] poet you know
like [ __ ] just put it out however it
comes out it will get the more you put
it out I'm I'm better at putting it out
than I was a decade ago I've kept
putting it out putting it out and then
it gets refined it doesn't get refined
in your head
it gets refined by living it right can
get it good thank you I want to see you
and I'm Minton I got that like on my
ticket I hope that really trying to get
there one time cancel on the second time
in the fall I'm worried about we'll see
what happens but I will get my ass to
admitted I'm committed all right you
soon take care
thank you thank you I love this swing
for the ring good to see you Stephen
Potter great to see you wanted to get
your thoughts on something please on
YouTube there's someone that's kind of
spamming I'm yet and everyone's telling
me to ban him but I'm not gonna because
it's obviously not my call yeah look I
think you know I saw it on twitch a
little bit I'm seeing on a YouTube a
little bit like I think we're gonna need
to consider mods so why don't why don't
we why don't we you know everybody's
kind of looking right now Gustin not
Justin as your Instagram handle right
yeah maybe
and let's not over flood Dustin if you
genuinely want to be a mod meaning you
want to be here every day and you want
to you know you feel like you understand
me which is don't ban too early I like
when people razz me
it's just when somebody just spams I
mean that's what it is it's not someone
arising you know history I know that's
what you're saying but we may need to
need some some mods so we'll talk about
that okay
he's already still doing it no I try I
asked him nicely if you could just cut
it like try to stop a little bit he said
he pretty much told me to [ __ ] off
hello my friend most adverse I call you
hello look under me
I can hear you what's your name
my name is Martha car I'm I'm surrounded
by a rock in every city I am 18 years
old never to question clear so you can
distribute rock on the first one is I
like you in a speech and how you
communicate with people and be effective
in newest with new speech I do mention
about how the voice technology will make
them better in the future
yes thank you through the value that
good level and now it's talking in part
of all not big audience don't mix you I
exactly what makes you hold it by boxing
and how you arrange the topics that you
want talking about and how you
what's the steps do you take before the
evening because when I see you on their
games I saw you're working in your form
I kind of think gonna happen what's
what's make you uncomfortable from the
inside I'd let you focus on work what's
your go see I you know what so I think
the question is when I'm when I'm
communicating you know how am I able to
gather my thoughts so I know what I'm
talking about on stage how do I make
that transition
how do what's my process to know what I
want to be communicating about in that
scenario whether it's on stage or
somewhere else
is that right Mo's yep just how it how
you focus on what you must do how let's
make you comfortable on the inside and
yeah let you focus
understand so in that exact to that
point and you went even more thoughtful
I appreciate that
what is it in me that allows me to be so
comfortable confident and and then quiet
and focused that it lets me articulate
at the level that I do is it
I think the I think it's like this is
where this is a very fun moment for me I
think it comes down to
experience experience I think a lot of
people want to speak early on and things
that nature
the number one reason I'm able to
there's many things I have natural
improv in comedic improv capabilities
I'm very comfortable in all scenarios I
have an amazing relationship with
adversity and and tough situations so
going on stages as tough as it gets for
a lot of people but I'm okay if it
doesn't go well I also think experience
so it's an experience and adversity
my relationship with adversity I'm okay
with anything happening the mic doesn't
work people boo me they think it's
stupid it's all fine for me that
relationship with that versity number
two I only talk about what I know too
many people talk about things they don't
know too many people want to talk about
things that they haven't lived yet that
they haven't experienced that they're
not experts in they talk about it
because it's the cool thing or a hot
thing or the important thing they talk
about [ __ ] they don't know it's not the
truth
so I speak my truth and I have a
relationship with that versity which
means on a moment's notice if you will
if most if you were like hey Gary my
screens now gonna turn to five hundred
thousand people in Iraq and I need you
to give a keynote I would do it right
now right now I would say tea I'm sorry
I have to give this half a million
person keynote my friends and family and
I you know like I would go right into it
so I think it's about staying in my lane
only talking about what I know and being
unbelievably comfortable with adversity
that's what you believe in a hundred
percent I believe in myself because I
don't care what people think about me
it's my relationship with judgment I
don't care
and what I mean by that of course I care
I'm a human being but I can't value it
more than my own happiness
I can't live on somebody else's terms I
can't
it's a bad idea Oh
how to make the balance between your
opinions and the data that your help
data shows you yesterday
my intuition helps me with tomorrow
I respect data but only after the fact
there is no data of the future and I
only play in the future I only play
what's in front of me work tomorrow
right now and tomorrow
yesterday's yesterday there is no
dwelling there is no you know what was
me there is no oh that's how it was I
take the past and I context it it
happened the past is what told me tick
tock was gonna be important because I
watched I've experienced on how fine
how Twitter how Instagram how snapchat
happened so I saw the patterns I saw the
patterns so I respect the past but I
don't overdo l on it and I know and when
somebody says to me well Gary 86% of
people buy their products at stores not
on e-commerce in America I'm like yes
that was yesterday now we have koban
things are gonna change so it's that
balance
I appreciate my friend I wish you well
thank you for being on the show
just the two question I have just the
next second is I worked up about three
years in a dad's horse company coats
could sell those come let's run it by my
uncle and my dad my work is in this
company is Horace photographer I just
want you to see my work in this case
maybe in scrap pile
please I didn't matter the entire
process in my working but I was some
example in my profile so hope you can
see it I see if not of course I will
take a look at it doesn't set me up all
right
okay just I was I worked in this company
to is the right car specifications and I
have a powerful knowledge about the car
specification and I worked a supervisor
at our work with particles divisions and
cars in Houston and I worked there as
our website Edmund
what what what well but I worked in my
spare time is enough multiple things
like video editing and programming but I
didn't achieve the level of from
professionalism as I think because
because I spent my time is in it as a
hobby that make sense you're a kid you
were a kid you were 15 to 18 yeah yeah
you're a [ __ ] kid i watch all yeah
that's why i'll save you time on the
answer you know kid
my girl you walk i watch a lot of your
DS for this video I investigate the same
I am and what how the business world my
addressing in marketing and branding and
maybe in the future go to businesses I'd
love that man
well can I know each other if you know
what's requirements maybe I can work in
your company I've been looking forward
to working with you for a long time
I also happy as any success might be in
the marketing listen I burn more than
yes yes I appreciate you taking a shot
good news for you miss it you were
required yep good news working for three
I'm going to take very first and that
I'm working here on your quartering even
if you want to select new training in
the beginning I show you my Google teams
because my Google is my goal is to learn
yeah
I appreciate it listen me not good news
now that we're warm or open to remote
work we may have a shot I'm gonna dust
and connect us after this and we'll get
to talking next week or two okay
yes all right good luck brother let's
get going thank you okay thanks for all
of you who are watching bearing with it
cuz obviously you oughta was a little
tough but uh I just liked him and wanted
to get through that so let's keep it
going
moe
hey life is good brother how are you I'm
doing fine I want to thank you a lot for
this amazing a program that you're doing
like I've learned so much it's the best
[ __ ] content and not really but I'm out
there thank you so much where are you
from brother thank you
I'm originally from Lebanon but I'm
currently in Denmark like I've been
living in Europe for the past five years
and I think it helped me a lot in many
aspects a lot and ye yeah like I'm just
gonna give you a small backstory and
then you know you can help me a bit
better I think so I came from Lebanon
and I studied in Poland I studied
medicine and I finished my medical
degree this year and the thing with
medicine is like
you know like it's a very demanding a
profession especially in residency you
need so much work you need to work like
really long hours and it's very
difficult you know and I want this thing
where I want to really empower others
especially young people because I've
been there I've been in this third-world
country and I know how difficult it is
actually to go outside that community
you know and how to find that
opportunity outside so I just want to
help
like people because I had this
scholarship back there so I want to help
like more people have more opportunities
to just do the things that I want how
would you do that
like I think by the you know like there
is many ways to do it I agree a big
factor can be like like financially it
can be very helpful like helping them
getting the education that they want
supplying them with a jobs that they can
get some valuable knowledge in you know
like many many stuff you know like I see
people out there and they are like
studying studying for long years and
there is no jobs and a market for what
they are studying yes because because
the modern education system globally is
has some substantial flaws in it
compared to what the people think
they're getting out of that education
the promise of the 1950s 60s 70s and 80s
even 90s of like if you go to university
or if you go to you know to your point
even even some of the things that are
still safe legal and medical things that
nature like it's it's a very different
world out there with the internet and
you know the the promises that have been
made for generations are vulnerable
right now obviously there's still plenty
of careers where if you get that degree
that is the only way to get in but
people are massing enormous amounts of
debt the amount of money that they're
getting in return is not where it used
to be especially in the medical field in
other places and yes I agree there's
major vulnerabilities with the system
yeah so this leads me to my question
which is like
how can I Gary like balance my career as
a doctor and my person to empower others
given like the very demanding a
profession you know like it yet you need
some time to help others and how can you
make up that time by auditing all your
leisure can you please explain me what I
can I want to know every hour of your
life when you're not doing your medical
field and you're not sleeping I'd like
to understand every hour
I understand but look the problem is
yeah go ahead I understand it's like
like working like I haven't started
working yet but I'm gonna start working
in them oh okay and I've done some
internships so I've seen exactly what's
the work like a like an internship for
like a month and they have and I've
lived it I understand it's like very
demanding job you start working at 7:30
in the morning and you finish work by
five or six you are completely exhausted
you need to go and eat something and he
was really tired and you end up sleeping
and waking up at 6:00 in the morning on
the weekends you will have shifts maybe
every two weekends you will have like a
weekend off but that's mostly it yeah so
a couple things I've always wanted to
help people too and in the beginning of
my career I didn't do it because the
internet wasn't at scale and I was
working retail you know six or seven
days of the week you know and I was
working much longer hours than you're
referring to you know I would have to
store it 7:38 then open at 9:00 I would
work until it was closed at 9:00 p.m.
and then I would go home and so I very
much understand and I would work that's
I would work 9:00 to 10:00 p.m. on
Friday and Saturday every single day for
seven eight years so maybe you're maybe
the answer to your question is you can
help people in seven years not today
when I talk about patience I really talk
about patience if you're telling me that
your job is gonna milk you so hard and
and why are you not to have the energy
to help well then you don't have the
energy to help
now it's just now it's just ideology I
ideology she's me now you're just saying
you know you'd like to which is fine
I just don't think you have to you know
beat yourself up that you're not doing
it yet maybe you can do it in five years
mm-hmm like the thing is like I've seen
like many people and in some way they
are able to to to do it like I'm sure
you have like so much work to do so many
things to do but still you can find
because because I don't because I don't
fear messing up okay the reason most
people are able to do more is because
they don't lack they don't fear losing
they don't fear failure people that fear
failure don't do things
there's a reason I'm so fast is I don't
put perfection on a pedestal
eighty percent of something done is
better than zero percent of something
done if you help one person by doing a
one-hour Skype when you said you still
have two to three months I laughed in my
head I literally laughed mm-hmm cuz I
said okay great yeah so [ __ ] help
people for next two to three months you
could be on the [ __ ] Internet twelve
hours a day I like young people it's
good that yeah yeah like I'm tea with
Gary Vee like it and because he helped
me just more I think it's more very
important more yeah yeah I think so I
think I will just need to work more on
it for more you know some days you're
gonna feel energized after work and from
9:00 to 11:00 p.m. you're gonna lay in
bed and make content and answer
somebody's question and you know DM
somebody to be on their podcast because
you know you have that weekend off in
two weeks this is a very simple game is
that you're doing it or you're not
either you're doing it in real life or
you're doing it in your head and in real
life it works better that's cool yeah
awesome
takeyama and that's why I like your
content because it's practicality thank
you very much you're welcome brother
thank you it is practicality like
they're there it's actions
over everything the reason I get into
mindset and and some bigger issues is
because they're the seeds that don't
lead to action let's keep going dude how
are you Gary good man thanks how are you
good man what's your name my name's
Chris catch yachty from Sudbury Ontario
Canada
it's a pleasure Chris between the five
hat and the work hard like I'm feeling
you already right yo Gary this this hat
is the local Sudbury professional
basketball team this every five I've got
I obviously had because I had to wear
I'll send you one I appreciate it and
there's a story that you told about bath
fascinated by it where you went to the
Knicks game with the ugly sweater and
sat courtside and that kind of had a
whole bunch of attention on you and on
the jumbotron and I kind of applied that
yeah
Sports Center when I when I go to
basketball games I have sat courtside
for the inaugural season last year well
season tickets on the court and I wore
this like fuzzy flannel II kind of
colorful jacket red red pants that the
whole stadium can see and I became like
a superfan almost so that was built on
the back of that story that you told
with the Knicks ugly sweater
I appreciate the crisp looking so I what
uh yeah so first off I want to start off
I know you don't here I know you don't
hear compliments but I know that you're
that you're very interested in legacy so
I just want to thank you from the bottom
of my heart for all of the all of the
guidance that you've been giving me from
afar for the last five years I mean it's
you drive home so many important
concepts and you've really changed the
way I think a lot of a lot of things and
its really had a massive impact on my
life and you're actually changing the
course of humanity I believe with by
making things like patience and
gratitude patience gratitude hardwork
empathy kindness you're making these
cool and your impact
not only my generation but younger
generations the older generations are
impacting the entire planet and you are
gonna reach your goal of everyone on
earth knowing who you are and when they
do you're gonna make the world a much
better place so I just wanted to start
off with that thank you for what you can
help me with is I work for the YMCA of
Northeastern Ontario so in the
not-for-profit sector and I got there by
after 9 years in the private
construction industry worked my way up
from site superintendent up to a junior
partnership offer but it just wasn't
lighting my soul on fire wasn't making
me happy I wasn't really passionate
about it yep
so but it was making good money and I
had an opportunity to make a lot of
money for my family and provide for my
family so I kind of grinded it out I
respect but in 2017 our son was
diagnosed in utero with some with a
fairly like a really insane and critical
heart disease so you hear that thank you
and he had open heart surgery at birth
and during the recovery process and kind
of taking all this into consideration I
just came to the realization that life
is just far too short to be spending it
doing something that you don't love so I
left with I left I joined I jumped in
with the Y and now I feel like I've
really found my links I get to use my
talent skills and passions and
everything that makes me me is an asset
and a strength and I get to deploy that
to make the community that I live in a
better place I love you for that thank
you so the long winded way to get into
this question is how do i how do I apply
the 5149 rule or giving more than I take
into fundraising whereby the main
function of my role is to get is to
depend on other people's generosity when
those people are not the the benefactors
of that generosity by asking them what
you can bring to the table hey old rich
dude in
neighborhood who can actually afford to
pay a check that will help the YMCA even
though none of his family or people he
knows are there what can i Chris in any
shape or form bring you in value I'm not
kidding
yeah that's actually the answer know
what I think fundraisings of real I
think it's one of the most interesting
moves and fundraising
instead of doing what most people do
which is try to guilt or play towards
one's bleeding heart yeah I think the
question is what can I do for you right
okay and that's what you'd be shocked I
mean I've seen I've seen things cuz I
I'm quiet with what my fundraising but
I'm on a lot of boards I do a lot of
stuff right and it's wild what some of
the answers are like sometimes the
answer looks like my daughter struggling
with swimming and you or your best
friend happens to be a great [ __ ]
swimmer and it's literal I'm not kidding
it's literally checked to YMCA your best
friend is teaching his or her daughter
to swim right okay so right okay so
basically it basically boils down to
understanding the people you are
approaching to be donors by and asking
them what you could bring to them in
value you don't even need to understand
I don't even know send [ __ ] I can walk I
can walk up to Sir Winston Thompson and
be like Hello Sir Winston Thompson what
is the most interesting things to happen
in your world the most interesting the
reason I'm sitting here luckily our
friend Karen put us together is I want
you to write a check to the YMCA cuz I'm
passionate here's my story my son's
heart condition didn't that already puts
you in a good spot I'm here not looking
for you to write a check out of the
goodness of your heart because I want to
make this practical what on earth can I
help you with I'm a social butterfly I'm
connected to a lot of people I have a
lot of my own skills I will believe for
you in return for what you want because
I want you not even for me I want you to
give that money to the YMCA that is a
[ __ ] killer pitch yeah yeah that is a
killer pitch right okay so the end just
the end approach people ask them what
they want or approach people ask them
what they want and an obviously and
obviously the way that
you approach it that will your success
rate will be on your cadence will be on
your on your skillset in asking some
people are gonna be dopey about it
some people gonna walk up to somebody be
like yo what do you want and it's like a
girl they're like scared like you know
like you have to find your cadence your
tact
your ability but it is the punchline of
the question period it will ya it will
outperform every other way you go about
it it would work on me I don't want to
see your [ __ ] picture of the [ __ ]
playground you're gonna build with my
money I don't care about the cute
picture of the kids of course I do that
is a given I understand that to be true
it's not that I don't care and I'm
heartless it's that I know what the [ __ ]
you're up to the YMCA is super branded I
get it right what I what I want it like
if you come at me with what do you want
from me I'm like wow you know that's
powerful right because no one's really
it doesn't seem like in the fundraising
world that a lot of people are taking
that approach they're not at all
everyone I tell my non-profit friends
all the time you're audacious just
because somebody has money why the [ __ ]
should they give it to you my brother
has Crohn's disease I want to give that
money to that I have [ __ ] I got
highest the foundation to help my family
get out of rush I want to get to that
like why am i you know what you know
people want to give to things that they
care about not what you care about right
so then a way to kind of sweeten the
deal is on top of the altruistic nature
of it what's in it for me basically 100%
what can I do for you yep and if you end
up [ __ ] you know shoveling snow yeah
there you go I would show us though I do
that me too me too
life's about value exchange and too many
people look at the people that are in a
position to give and they just think
that they should give it lacks complete
empathy it lacks any kind of kindness
it's a completely audacious it's a it's
an unbelievable as if it's it's it's
just it's just not fair you don't know
anything about them you don't know how
they made their money you don't know
what they're doing currently you don't
know their actual situation people just
[ __ ] think that they should as if
like hey why aren't you doing this Sir
Winston settings writing a ten thousand
dollar check is easy for you you don't
know right yeah exactly you know that
[ __ ]
so ask for what you can bring to the
table period and the story guilt guilt
and expectations don't work no no I'm
not I'm not into that
I'm not into guilt I'm not into playing
the victim in any way in any way shape
or form I mean that's one of the major
kind of mindsets that I have and again
based on a lot the two major themes that
you that you preach accountability and
accountability and gratitude is that
accountability plus grad Q is a choice a
choice to say when you're presented with
a difficult decision you have a choice
to either crumble use it under the
excuse and kind of break down or order
to push through develop as a human and
actually come out on the other side
Chris asked people what you could do for
them yeah okay sweet one more thing one
more thing so I've just in January in
January I launched a children's book I
wrote a children's book 10% of its going
to sick kids I actually sent one to your
office a couple months ago I don't know
I don't know if it made its way to I
don't know if it made its way to Misha
and Xander but I appreciate it brother
I'll ask Lu and Alex I'm sure they're
watching or Justin will let them know
I'll look for what's the name of it it's
called my very excellent mother just
served us nine pizzas that's not that
yeah it's a it's a it's a it's a
pseudonym for how we learn how to
memorize the names that the order of the
planets
growing up when you're in school I love
that but checking in on that wasn't the
reason for this question is actually
tactical question on I just basically
the way I've been marketing these books
is like guerrilla marketing on my
personal page I've sold like 700 units
pushing 800 units on getting consignment
deals I'm getting like corporate buyers
or buying big bulk numbers do you have a
fence awesome I don't have a Facebook
group no I started a Facebook page but
I've been slacking on getting a going
same thing with Instagram Facebook and
Instagram are your two platforms for
this book yeah okay and it's kind of and
what kind of content pillars do you
think independent publishing co could
what about you what about the book
one about you know the first fans of the
book you know just the content right and
I guess a Gary that a lot of the support
that I've been a lot of the support that
I've gotten off the initial phases of
this book have been completely
predicated on things that I've learned
from you and about like personal
branding and giving more and no
expectations and everything everything
that's been happening with this book has
basically been built on kind of the
model that you've been preaching since
I've started listening to you so that
you executed I have super admiration
brother lots of people listen to me most
don't execute keep doing write on you I
love you pal talk you so love you bro
take care nice kid like that dudes
energy a lot all right let's keep it
moving oh [ __ ] UGK for life all right I
hope I get to play you someday anyway
I do it I just want to put out there
thank you for everything I didn't even
hear about your house until about two
months ago this conversation has the
potential to change the trajectory of
music education globally I feel so I
want to just briefly talk about me
because it's not about me
raised in Missouri I'm 41 world champion
drummer world champion drum instructor I
breed world champion drummers my one of
my students just recently played the
Emmys later in life in my 30s here comes
dubstep producer for like ten years some
people would say one of the pioneers in
American dubstep play with Bassnectar
pretty lights played in 48 states
festivals coast to coast I had a record
label called Al's dope records and it's
a blew up in my face in 2018 because I
ended up over-promising spread myself
then yep I ended up getting on at a
corporate music school that has a movie
and Broadway musical named after it you
know jack box the star and they brought
me on as a drum structor than the music
director than the general manager and I
was at a franchise so I real
wanted to start this EDM and DJ program
like hip-hop EDM production DJ program
for the kids so I lined it up been
working on it I launched it at my
franchise in Denver and then there's a
company school
I'm originally from Missouri so there's
a there was a position open in Kansas
City I started flying back and forth
every week this year before COBIT and
really thought that corporate was gonna
finally bite on it right but they're
really stuck on ACDC Nirvana
Pearl Jam that's I have a thing they're
not uh they're not really you know I
keep getting push back alright so here
we are is eight weeks in the Kogan push
back push back in the form of like this
is not real music and we love and we
love grunge better like on some
subjective [ __ ] in the form of like yeah
I mean you know that's most of what
happens in the world I just want to make
sure I'm grounded and what the pushback
is yeah I mean a push back is you know I
finally thought they were gonna let me
do it this corporate school because I
got their attention because we had a
successful season like the program is
lit and [ __ ] it succeeds bro ok so
where I'm at with the bro is you know I
had the conversation with the software
companies and let them know what's up
they're down and uh you know I feel like
I keep getting this well well let's talk
about it in 18 months we'll talk about
it then well that's [ __ ] port that's
corporate right exactly right that's
what you signed up for bro yeah well
well nothing no you you took it at bat
in entrepreneurship you miss played it
you know your youngest [ __ ] still you're
resetting and corporate so you eating up
the [ __ ] fat piece of [ __ ] and and
now we're gonna make some new decisions
yes right so that's why we lost Bank you
studio.com
all of these uh all of these lessons
online right dudes through zoom it's
more like a mental health checkup and
what I'm realizing is like doing the
music production on Ableton through zoom
is way more efficient and productive
because I can annotate right there on
this screen we get work done through
zoom and so I guess really want I'm at
Gary
is I'm gonna do this regardless I'm here
to double down on my strengths I know
what I do is gonna happen regardless
School of Rock sorry they didn't holler
back and I said you know what if they
don't holler back by the time I get on
here with Gary Vee what's the worst he's
gonna say is No so Gary me my question
to you is do you have any interest in
helping launch the school of hip-hop and
EDM um probably no but not for a bad
reason like I really believe in it and I
genuinely believe just on your energy
that it's gonna work my biggest thing
right now is my liquid situation because
I've got to save my own businesses in a
global pandemic it's not where I want it
to be some students head down
plus my stopgap kind of my insurance
policy
always was well I always have my
personal brand speaking career and
that's gone from something significant
to dead [ __ ] zero right and then it
goes into savings lands so the timing
I'm just not in that spot right now
right yeah yeah
but but you know I think that if you
want to email me at Gary of vaynermedia
what you think financially it needs to
get off the ground I'm happy to populate
it a little bit because I have a ton of
friends in music who might find it more
passionate and and and more compelling
cuz I can tell you right now the the
energy is there the question is what did
you learn from the over-promising
under-delivering
and your cash flow management on the
record label however record labels are
much more high-risk high-reward than a
school where you're getting revenue in
it every time so I'm happy to look at
that and I don't need a [ __ ] business
plan I need [ __ ] six sentences that
tell me what the [ __ ] you're up to
alright yo bro you are my Russian Jesus
I got you cat I wish you well take care
let's get one more in here desk
hi Melissa I'm you hey Gary
hi Melissa I didn't think I was gonna
get on I'm so excited I'm glad we made
it happen I'm very grateful to be here
and I echo your team's been really
awesome amazing customer service thank
you so my question to you and if you
want context I can give
- but when do you decide to give up a
project or a side hustle when you decide
to like we're not genuinely you know
there is no like look there have been
people that have given up on a project
and a side hustle literally one month
before it was gonna pop the amount of
people that you know were meant to be
quote unquote music famous but gave up
at it at 27 when their next song was
gonna be what was gonna make them hit
and now they're an accountant I believe
in that but I believe that percentage is
much smaller much smaller call that the
1% to the 99% that are delusional and
tone-deaf to the response of the market
and are still grinding at something that
the world has told them they're not good
at yeah so I have a protein bar called
it fits Bart's down here and it launched
it launched awesome in 2017 it was great
and then I had all of these
manufacturing issues so I lost customers
I lost all my store you know things got
super tough and crazy and then in 2018 I
have a disease called endometriosis um
kind of like Crohn's like what you're
saying with your brother and I had had
this big surgery and I remember like
laying in bed like in the hospital bed
like being on Instagram for the brand
and I was like you know this is like I
have to change this so I stepped back
and found a different manufacturer which
has been great and their local I'm in
Detroit they're local here in Detroit
yeah much love back
yeah and that and that story's gonna
resonate right like if there's like let
there be no confusion post this pandemic
like made in America is gonna have a
real surge people are gonna like the one
time people will pay more is when they
want to feel safer and and that will
happen that just is gonna happen for at
least half the audience of America so
keep going yeah I hope so so I take the
step back I haven't really been like
pushing anything on that social Channel
and in this time like read I suffer from
this chronic illness and I'm like I got
to start to go in on all this there's no
awareness on this I'm super passionate
about it right and so I start this
podcast that is doing actually really
well I've been doing it for two years so
like my focus a little bit shifted but
now I'm ready to relaunch the protein
bar and I'm just like in the pandemic
and like all of this
now my day gig which is in marketing and
e-commerce which you know all about is a
24/7 job unfortunately mine is not going
to be going forward after this
coronavirus stuff and that's what's been
funding all of these kind of hobbies is
what I like to call them so I just I'm
kind of at this crossroads like I don't
want to give up on the protein bar but
I've never made a dime on it
and should I give up on it but I think
it potentially has legs absolutely not
even the way you're talking about it it
has too much happiness attached to it
are you I think the bigger question is
now the practice so the emotional part I
would say no like listening to you the
answers my can take no now we need to
layer the practical part right if you're
if you're losing money on this and and
you can't afford to lose money you might
just need to take a pause yeah yeah I
mean and then the question becomes can
you make money like can you no can it
become a moneymaker like for example you
know yeah you know you got a local
producer of it now
I'm sure the costs are a little bit
higher but you've got the stability of
it you know are you able to charge more
or will customers push back because 30
million or Adam for jobs and like [ __ ]
you with the with the protein bar twice
as expensive as everything else well and
when I first launched it someone said
there's a thousand protein bars at Whole
Foods why would you do that
and that almost like that's the old me -
yeah [ __ ] that like that's a that's a
ridiculous there's nothing that is
invented whoever that friend or relative
or co-worker or family member is needs
to get punched in the face yeah I was
like but the competitive price like what
you were saying with price like that's
like I have to be in a certain range but
what if what if you're what if you
innovate what if your protein bar that
anybody that buys a 12-pack gets part of
a closed zoom group and all of you get
together once a month and now all of a
sudden your protein bar is $6 instead of
a dollar how much are protein bars but I
mean under $2.99 is probably really
where you want to be got it so what if
yours was actually $5.99 when you buy a
24 is it in a case 12 24 12 12
what if yours was $5.99 for a 12-pack
you get two you get a code inside of the
box when you buy it in a 12-pack only
you only sell them in 12 packs we're
innovating now yeah what I do well yeah
yeah when you get it you get a unique
code that gets you confirmation to get
into a group that gets to talk for it
what if you mix both of your worlds what
if this is actually targeted towards
females and you know me well that's kind
of odd oh yeah I mean I made it because
I struggle with certain foods so it's
very and gluten free so so why don't why
don't why don't you become the first
person that makes it a Content access
bar not just the bar so now the bar is
72 bucks the case now you're making a
couple bucks and now you're sitting in a
closed zoom or Google hangout each to
twice a month for three hours building
community and and maybe providing some
sort of value or content based on like
my knowledge for what I know but the
value is you're the Pied Piper you're
throwing the tea party virtually like
now all these women are gonna have a
community you guys are gonna be friends
that's the value you're the orchestrator
you're a conductor of this [ __ ]
incredible community that is clearly
gonna be epic if people are buying a $72
case of protein bar just to be it's
gonna be the community part that they're
actually buying yeah [ __ ] good idea
I want you to do this I want this is
what I want I mean I have to still find
a date something you know what it's
still this latter is I just [ __ ] gave
you a real business idea it's I'm gonna
know like I've been thinking like I have
this successful should the bar sponsor
the podcast like I've been thinking
about that like could you like how I'm
better at business than you I've learned
something better on the spot here you go
here you go
you're you now sell it direct for 72
bucks a case only you can't buy what
it's only I only sell it [ __ ] third
party places okay you're the only one
that sells it it's 72 bucks when you now
you don't even need to come wait a
minute now I'm pumped with you being the
only one who's selling it [ __ ] the
little code you've got all the
information you just email B look look
seeing me like yours
I'm your email is now gonna be the email
you just bought this with is now allowed
into this [ __ ] password-protected
community
I'll see you Friday nights from 6:00 to
8:00 twice a month can't wait to see you
you're gonna [ __ ] kill this you think
people actually do that I'm convinced
I'm completely calm people do it's even
better it's even better than that
everybody was watching right now don't
just do it to be nice and then if you're
actually interested in what's your email
Melissa at boo or Melissa it fits bar if
you want to yeah Melissa and it fits bar
super easy right so I'm gonna wait for
Dustin do his thing make let's make sure
this is the right email yeah like I'm
looking I'm reading the comments across
all the pieces I think there's a lot of
women that would join this like people
like friends there's a there's a solace
yeah yeah yeah wait wait
yeah one in ten women have this disease
like it's very prevalent in 200 million
women right and so to me if those thing
women are paying three bucks for a
protein bar they like now they're paying
six dollars but for that extra three
dollars they're gonna be part of a close
community that's gonna become a
sisterhood [ __ ] you know which more
expensive therapies yeah you know
expensive a glass of wine is when you go
out with some girlfriends to dwell it's
a [ __ ] deal this might be too cheap we
may have to make a ninety nine dollars a
12-pack I love you I love you I really
do
I genuinely think it's a great idea I
think it's gonna find more do this I
will do and I will tell you I'll follow
up with you I will do this is such a big
idea that most people should follow this
I think this is a model meaning like
everybody right now that has a product
should go to this model it's access yeah
like if I made empathy forty bucks but
it came with an hour of me let out
[ __ ] be ten times bigger yeah an hour
with me with everybody you know what I
mean like yeah yeah yeah yeah no I agree
with us that you should you know but
doesn't put me email that Jesus know the
spelling error you [ __ ] up again
it's you can't spell for [ __ ] Dustin no
it's okay Dustin you can find me you can
DM me on Instagram - I would have my
handles up there all three of them okay
I mean I obviously have a little extra
time now - Jim can you check your email
real quick and see if he has he doesn't
yet know your yeah yeah yeah yeah can
you check it real quick on its how many
people are gonna show you buy this thing
for 72 to ninety nine dollars I'm think
about raising it to ninety nine dollars
seriously it's a clump you're paying for
the club and then you're getting the
bars what else can what else should the
club offer just for um I just hope
you'll build on
you'll you know just like that nice kid
Chris earlier with the nonprofit at
first you'll be like hey guys or a
[ __ ] Gary right we're and you're
comfortable you get to know each other
and then then it gets rolling then
you're doing y night then you're [ __ ]
make a t-shirt then you're like fitting
it like I'm into fitness too which is
kind where little bit about yeah you'll
do a workout regimen like you know it's
it's gonna work I have two emails but a
bunch people are following me on
Instagram two is better than zero and
everybody's watching right now so as
soon as the sense
everyone's gonna actually email you but
I really really really think well is
what if I could bring like fitness
people on or do cooking class I mean I
could make it I could just create a
whole series of music so I'm sitting
right now people right at night people
gonna pay $99 for the bar I think the
way you do it is you do it by monthly so
they just sign up for the subscription
basically they're paying $600 a year to
be in the club yeah every - every you
know every every month every buy month
they get the $99 bucks for you know with
12 bars yeah they can reorder more ad
hoc
if they'd like because maybe some of the
people like like this bar better than by
other bars like I think it's very real
uh if this comes true you literally just
like made my dreams come true
listen I have something better for you
this is a hundred percent gonna come
true I'm desperately hoping it happens
for you but right now there are hundreds
of people deciding to use this business
model this is actually a business model
right this is a big model like somebody
with peanut butter somebody with
t-shirts right a buddy of music like
people gonna do this I'm completely
convinced well I mean maybe we should
just leave them build it as a business
model and that's like another snap keep
your ambitions down let's be practical
here this is where people get [ __ ]
oh we're gonna build a [ __ ] plan no
no no yeah yeah yeah there's an executor
I promise you I believe I like your
energy I can feel it listen yeah
ninety-nine bucks a month real quick I
listen I want to know from everybody in
the community that it literally apply
I'm in if you're actually gonna sign up
for the $99 protein community bar I want
to I want to see in if you're in I'm
really curious like they'll say I'm in
right now that's that's the way to
register essence
I'm telling around Dustin's gonna start
showing you all the ones right now yeah
better then I'm going to manufacturing
tomorrow like I will I'm gonna turn it
here's better this this is such a great
community
the money from everybody on presale I'm
writing you right now like Shane Barnes
is in Thank You Susan
Merrill Lord is in thank you yes Lissa
this is gonna work I'm telling you
frosty TVs in V Docs is in this is
amazing this is awesome
it's gonna work I and now you have a
framework now you can promote yeah
you're I mean you're literally changing
my life and making something I dream
about come true I didn't think about it
this way because because because I'm
creative in like what I'm good at is
seeing things that other people don't
think that's what I'm good at that's why
innovating wine tech by the way
oh you're Michigan you have you're fine
you're fine I I do by empathy and send
it to everyone for Christmas I love you
just so you know I love you too please
post wine text yeah Facebook page and be
like oh my wines like you know
everyone's drinking wine like yeah you
know especially right now especially
shits blowing up [ __ ] is blowing up you
know what else is blowing up
it fits bar is blowing up the $99
bimonthly community that happens to sell
protein bars I appreciate you there
they're vegan and gluten-free people but
they taste delicious but here's the best
part you're gonna build a community yeah
and people are gonna get these bars
they're gonna start passing out the bars
you know when somebody so many people
gonna value the $600 for the community
because you're [ __ ] your energy is on
point
this is why I'm giving you this idea
you're very good at it I think you're
gonna be good at it I think a lot of
people that have been on the show
wouldn't be good at being the Pied Piper
of the community yeah if I did this I'd
[ __ ] make 14 trillion a year on it I
know I want to do thank you for this
advice I mean 40 trillion or V but you
don't you know what's good like for
example like somebody said it's over too
expensive and and I understand that from
yeah the Breanna physical because she's
looking at the literal execution a bar
should be not $6 or $3 I get it yeah and
by the way to her point she might jump
on here and say and there's other
communities that's great but it's gonna
be your community yeah you know I mean
yeah yeah yeah like my community for
sure and what I'm hearing - come on -
one of these - Phyllis relax I like the
salesmanship
though use that great salesman that was
a [ __ ] great pitch that was a super
gangster [ __ ] so everyone's gonna be
like I'm in
that's that's awesome I believe really
appreciate it one last question and this
is totally unrelated
were you sore after the plank challenge
you know what like you know cuz I kind
of did that downward dog like once she
told me we could do I didn't realize you
could do like on your hands I was always
like this yeah not not terribly I'm
super score today because I did [ __ ]
Bulgarian split squats yesterday which
are the [ __ ] worst
yeah they're I agree I probably agree
[ __ ] hate Dutch [ __ ] I did ABS this
morning which is super fun I'm starting
to actually like I I never eaten this
five and a half years that I finally got
my health together
I like abs are a byproduct of everything
else something but I've never gone ham
on abs and might like when I'm chunky
and I'm a little chunky right now
because of koban the MOT you know like a
lot of men like mine goes a little bit
to the tummy but like I'm really excited
about building up my like building a bad
muscles has been really into it
especially because my back issues yeah
and my so you know it's it's we're
really on that kick right now with Mike
which has been fun awesome
Gary I appreciate you thank you let's
put up your email one last time
let's put up Melissa's email listen
everybody I really want you to try to do
this I'll talk I'll give you guys first
several of you you should do this for a
reason you also have product ideas and I
think doing a year with Melissa and
watching how she does it
stumbling through it will help you
launch your peanut butter your flowers
your t-shirts your coffee version of
this I think there's a huge business
model I think I will recall this video
in seven years when this is a common
business model and I'll be like you know
don't you and I'll be like Gary changed
my life
thank you Gary you're welcome bye-bye
all right Dustin yes sir
super high end Pinot Noir today you know
and I know yesterday's Cabernet sold out
in like 12 minutes so a lot of people
looking for Father's Day gifts didn't
work out but today's is like a 48 dollar
wine I think it's gonna go for 22 bucks
Pinot which is like the hot grape
varietal I think I think it's a I think
it's pretty good stuff I said why are
people that are watching right now not
why have they not signed up for wine
text when they actually buy wine
obviously real quick yesterday I did the
whole joke about like will block you if
you if you've signed up for wine text
and you don't buy why
please and today's offer hit stop or
unsubscribe or whatever the
functionality is because we it costs
money to set attacks so you're being
very sweet but I don't want you on the
list if you're not a wine buyer but a
few minutes yeah I mean if you're buying
for corporate reasons or if you're a
real estate agent like like what I love
about wine Texas it's a great b2b thing
because yes should we sold a hundred
dollar wine for $39 when you give that
wine to your boss or a client and they
google it at $109 you get that clout but
you're all-right your cost is low that's
the I mean what's great about wine taxes
these prices are insanely on like like
that you know I don't know if you know
I've been telling you off-screen like
they're crazy deals I'm really excited
about a plea sign up for wine texts if
you have it I'm just gonna be the comet
scene up somebody signed up yesterday I
know a lot of people or I know Texas and
I know there's a lot of place you can't
ship to yes you can just send a gift to
us I would sign up for three phones if I
wasn't in I'm none unless I could not
tell you were joking yesterday it's
funny I am good sometimes
Gabriel cos thank you some people um yes
telling me that please don't ban me I
would never do that
but I am excited about wine text and and
if nothing else because we can't ship to
certain states because of their own
shipping laws Gabi Ramos wine Tex comm
is a service I create for my dad's wine
shop it's a deal of the day crazy deal a
day each day that comes in text form
when you sign up you put your credit
card in so all you have to do when you
get the text is hit reply with a number
of bottles you want and then we send it
to you it's been huge Massachusetts
you're in you can do it please go to
wine text if you have it and if you're
and if you're if you're yep Kerala South
Carolina you're good please go to the
site don't ask him Ohio you're good I
know you're asking your please go to
site you'll see the states that we can
or can't ship to but it would really
mean the world to me if you're a wine
drinker what's a little new doing today
and what he's like sad that he lost his
job now sign up but more importantly a
lot of you could really do this for me
it would really matter to me if you
could post it on either Twitter or your
Facebook I mean
book post is a monster you know like
somebody just posting like best wine
deals and I'm like we're getting like 1
or 2 signups from each one of those even
when people have just 20 or 30 or 40
friends because it's a cosign to your
community so it would really really
really matter to me if you could do that
so I think Kansas is good John please
sign up but again don't sign up if
you're not a wine buyer because it cost
money but the deals are sick today's
like $48 p no for like 22 bucks like
we've got a we've got a white wine I
just put the final touches on it'll be a
month from now but its $38 Chardonnay
dose up for $9 Dustin it's a good deal
sign up for my new Twitter account here
the details and the people that are
gonna win over the next five to seven
years are gonna be very comfortable and
controlled the process rules require
sacrifice all your actions have to then
map to route back back back back back
back nobody gives a [ __ ] about where you
grew up the whole game is scaling the
unscalable it's [ __ ] hard work it's
being respectful it's being a good
person to that that's just a good idea
it's there the flip things there this
helps right here there's $400 minute I
stay milady
like real [ __ ] tight but you can't be
crippled everybody here judging
themselves you're looking at what's in
front of you right now
you're losing cuz you're laying in your
bed looking at somebody's [ __ ]
glamorous photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool and you're envious
and you're jealous and you're impatient
and it's crippling your up side let me
just say it one more time if you're
confused what I just said I say put your
[ __ ] flag on the ground up who the
[ __ ] you are whoever provides the most
value always you're entering the
greatest five year window of your life
my only answer today or any much like
it's just like try [ __ ] shut your
business down and go work for an apparel
company pretenders
nobody you've ever met got there without
the hard work so you better get your
speed up you've been a work partner
you better work smarter if you can't
Google stuff you're not gonna be able to
do anything that I'm kind of Gary pptv
like he'll check me out hope you enjoy
it